hey guys how's it going
awesome 25 minutes and you guys get
snack time awesome well thank you guys
for having me first of all I want to
affirm you husband's heart it is it
stuff I want to tell you a quick story
seven years ago I was unemployed had no
idea maybe quarter life crisis something
like that and my prince said hey I got
this website and I'd literally just
checked my email like that's my
proficiency like I could check Gmail and
he was like hey dude yeah I got this
website I want you to help me build it
or whatever and I'm like I don't even
know the first thing about websites and
content or whatever and and it was tough
it was tough for three years it was an
automotive website where we had people
to get get together to talk about cars
and sell car parts and all this stuff
and it was extremely hard and there's
ups and downs and I'm sure you guys know
there's some days we put a ton of work
in you see like a little bit of movement
and you kind of sometimes it's hard to
stay motivated and this is true story so
like I had this shirt when I was in that
mindset I'm like I gotta get some
mindset you're good people say dude you
gotta do something else with your life
this is not going where but I believed
in it and all right this one shirt I
would put on and it said the world
belongs to those who hustle and I put it
on because I knew this there were people
that were smarter than me there are
people they're more talented there are
people more resources but no one was
gonna out-hustle me that was my thing
and I just want you to know there is
lively in the tunnel three years later
we were able to sell that business for a
few million dollars and I just want to
encourage you guys to just keep on
keepin on so yeah so you guys are here
that's a big part of it so thank you
guys for having me
[Music]
so anyways one question for you guys who
loves dogs okay alright we're in good
company what about horses horses Birds
we own all those domains it's crazy yeah
ferrets whatever but so anyways we
started off
years ago as a Facebook page we wrote
Facebook we're like hey people like dogs
let's start building some stuff for them
back in the day was easy to buy fans
things like that and it was I love dogs
and we had a website we're like we need
a website I guess like people are like
going places to read stuff like we are
posting dog pictures and dog videos and
all this stuff and my buddy was like all
right let's just grab URL so it was like
the Isle of Dogs site calm was the first
time we purchased and we started seeing
traffic we started writing content we're
like oh wow you know this is like people
like reading in they're going here and
so about a year into we're like yeah
that's - the URLs too long let's find
another domain name so I heart dogs came
up we're like let's do this
so we accidentally became a content
company it wasn't totally planned but
the cool thing is like really early we
realized like as pet owners ourselves we
need solutions and so one of the ways we
did that we started to write content
started out with kind of fun like
content and then we started writing more
and more detailed content about like
things owners need to know or health is
a big one - for us definitely one of the
things that we read a ton about so small
team bootstrapped in coffee shops and
then we're like man you know what like
you mean really cool is if like we could
write content for every single dog breed
and there's like two of us every day and
it was like little ambitious but we said
hey there's got to be a way to figure
this out so what I want to talk to you
guys today about is um how we bootstrap
a ton of content by working smarter not
harder
sound good okay cool here we go all
right site itself so we have a contact
commerce model being a media company is
tough today it's not impossible a lot of
people do it well we you know what we
really started with the vision of that
um in our mantra for our team is all
dogs matter every single dog matters and
every single cat matters and part of
that is our goal if like if we do
anything it's
to hell the happiness of pets period and
we're really aggressive about that we're
gonna do anything we possibly can so
when we started writing content people
like oh that's really cool like I just
found this out of my dog you guys helped
give me information but like what do I
do next
do I take do they give them a supplement
do it is there a special toy and so we
start doing research like you know we
want to connect the dots because when
they're ready to take action we want to
give them a solution that works but we
went out there and like this stuff sucks
it's like like we can't we don't feel
like we're doing them a service
sometimes because it's like we get them
ready you're like this is what you need
and then and then they're like okay cool
like where is that weird I go get it and
then all the options just weren't really
that great for them so we're like now
we're not we're not gonna do this we're
gonna build it we're gonna build it I
have no idea how we're gonna do we're
gonna do it so we launched a supplement
company we launched a toy company you
name it we're like we're just gonna do
it if we if people really need this
information and then they need to take
the next step and purchase something
where they give them the best thing that
we possibly can so we started that about
e-commerce about 36 months old and we
have a million customers so we content
we're very content heavy team 500 pieces
of content a month we have a team of
five that does that
and Facebook pages we run a hundred
Facebook pages we use it in conjunction
with content so this is something that
we do is kind of a hack because you can
buy likes for five or ten cents still
for most niches what we'll do is we'll
launch a page just to gauge the interest
of a community before we write content
to it so like here's an example senior
dog owner so dogs are older have
different conditions and needs and so
for us we're like we will really want to
test like how much content we should
write so he wrote some content but then
we actually launched a Facebook page in
a group and and targeted people who had
seen your dogs to see kind of how
responsive they would be to the content
first and it turns out they were so then
we double down on that started creating
more content so we'll actually launch a
lot of Facebook groups or pages just to
see where they really where people are
and so now we have way too many that's
100 is way too many but Facebook groups
another one too if you guys have there's
passion and
you're building so if you're writing
something for people we're very
passionate groups are really awesome
because that's actually they run it you
just got to moderate it so it's a really
cool thing if Facebook's investing by
the way big time and groups because it
keeps people on Facebook so they're
definitely so that's one of the things
we started pretty early there we go 5%
so the reality is that like for all the
hard work we do for all the stuff we
write only 5% of our content contributes
to 95% of our traffic in our revenue and
when you look at that number it's kind
of disappointing because like 95% of the
stuff that you slaved over and you
invested time in doesn't really make it
and so for us we're like man like how do
we how do we actually make that work
like how do we take this next level
because if we're just writing a hundred
pieces to have five work that's
expensive we don't have any money and we
have a limited amount team bandwidth
things like that so we're like all right
we can we're gonna hack this model and
I'm gonna get into how we do that here
in a minute but um so there's three
things when we looked at all the content
the 5% of content that does the best
there's three things we found out is
true one is its hyper relevant the best
kind of type of relevant and what I mean
by hyper relevant is it is extremely
specific to the people that you want to
talk to so there's general content so
like in the dog world we could write and
some of this does well it could be like
three it could be like something your
dog needs to know about their allergies
or something right if but if we if we
put in there you know three things you
need to know is a great day and owner
about your senior Great Dane
it's a lot more hyper relevant hyper
relevancy is everything for us so the
best content we have that performs it's
really really targeted to the audience
we want we're looking for it's not
general it tends to be hyper relevant
the other thing is it's there's a lot
about the value driven reciprocity what
I mean by this is like it's really got
to create value the hospital does is
great like when I get that newsletter I
feel like it was for me and there's so
much value created and there's something
that happens when we were given value I
don't know if you guys have ever seen
like
experiment at Starbucks we're like the
person in front end line buys the person
behind them a drink and then there's
this loop that happens where people just
keep buying each other drinks it's like
oh okay I'll buy this we're created
internally we're wired to reciprocate
value so for us if we can get them add
enough value to them then we can get
them to reciprocate it and a lot of
times that's in the form of maybe even
we do this with email so like if someone
if you give enough value and you say hey
give me your email I'll give you some
more stuff that's one way for products
it's a lot harder but that's really the
world we live in is like we want to
create so much value for them that
they're like all right there they have
my back they're gonna help me out and I
think the other thing that's really for
us is I think really important
especially when it comes to context I
said this is lost sometimes is it's got
to happen for us it's gotta have a clear
there's got to be a clear intent behind
it like we just all have time money
capital to write content just to write
content or just to fill a slot or just
to push out like it's gotta have a
purpose so all of our content before it
can God we look at okay what's the point
of this like really what's the point is
education great now what's what are we
educating them towards and how we gonna
help them connect those dots okay so
there's a lot of stuff going to show up
here but this is how we traffic hack a
lot of content the type irrelevant so
you guys all you guys will follow me in
this one all right so because 5% of our
content creates 95% of our traffic
revenue it's a lot of times we're wrong
when we're trying to guess like what
actually is gonna work or what's the
best solution so we kind of follow this
model so we write one really good piece
of content and we feel like it's good
that we feel like is relevant to a lot
of people okay and then we're gonna buy
traffic now just when I say buy traffic
I think that's a loaded word what I mean
really is if we use Facebook will
promote it to people who we feel like
are potential readers right to get a
baseline pretty quickly so we'll write
it and you generally you'll get some
kind of instant response a few hours
you're like you'll see that people are
really clicking to it at a higher
frequency of the other content
that's usually our baseline but then
here's what we do rather than just
having that piece
we'll take that piece right will create
five versions of that piece and then
we're gonna change the headlines and we
actually may even change the content
usually the first paragraph to see how
we can make it even more relevant to
people in that segment so an example
would be if it's a general dog piece
that the next one we're gonna take the
same content we're not going to rewrite
it we're gonna actually tweak it a
little bit and we're gonna five pieces
of content that are hyper relevant to
different audiences or different groups
from the same general piece of content
that clicked and we actually do that
over and over and over and over to the
extent where we'll have well have one
Jim one piece of content that does well
meaning it hits the right audience it
creates enough value it gains enough
traffic like that article will may spawn
a hundred pieces of content but every
single piece is different and it's
unique the general content tends to be
this similar but we'll make it really
specific for the audience that we're
actually targeting so we end up with
this a lot of really great pieces of
hyper relevant content and we didn't
have to create every single one from
scratch and so for us that works really
really well especially with Facebook
because you can make it hyper relevant
then target the right audience and then
the other part of it that we use is for
email opt-ins will will create a mop is
just for that audience too
so so yeah hi Brooke so you have a
general piece that you create hype
irrelevant pieces with and then so then
you create an emo often for that hyper
relevant audience if that makes sense so
like then you're then you really know
who people are and it's kind of like
fishing in a way right like it's like a
lure it's like you're getting people in
you're figuring out really who they are
and what their values are what they
they're looking for not just at a
general level but at a really really
local level and for us that information
is super valuable especially when you're
trying to offer solutions for them let's
see
and so the two things I think this is
brought up before so he is to add when
you add it when you're chained when
you're creating hyper relevant content
content it's variations you want to use
keywords that will pull that audience
specifically in stuff that they're
interested in
and so it's not like you want to just
copy it verbatim you want to make it
personal to that audience like the words
that they would use the words that
appeal to them and then relevant images
so you want to make sure the images
you're using a relative for the audience
that you're trying to target that all
makes sense so far good okay all right
so here's an example like we're in the
pet so it's I think this actually works
for a lot of different but I'm will take
this example one thing we'll do so
basically five natural allergy remedies
for docs right we want to figure out
people have problems with this turns out
that you have a lot of problems with
that and so then we go okay let's let's
see how much deeper this go so we'll
create three variations it will make it
specific so German Shepherds boxers and
labs right and out of that we found wow
this breed specifically has a lot of
allergy problems there's a lot of
readership and interest around it so
then we're gonna create another version
that takes that hyper relevancy and then
just actually magnifies it so the next
one we would try is algae remedies for
senior boxers of skin it's can irritate
versions like that so we'll use
versioning as a way to take a good piece
of content to extrapolate more people
out of the infrastructure Facebook
organic whatever to readership and the
idea is this we're gonna what we do is
we're going to offer them hard solutions
so like we're gonna offer them
supplements we're gonna offer them maybe
there's there maybe there's a ebook or
something on theirs so whatever we're
gonna do where we use this is actually a
way to build that product so if we have
enough and we did we enough people say
like I really have allergy problems with
my dogs and allergies I don't know what
to do so through all of that through
learning a lot of that we actually
started building supplements and now we
have some of the best supplements on the
market and that all came from versioning
some versions of content and it just
basically informed us into so what
really people are looking for so this an
example just a visual example of like
what this looks like on the site we hide
all these pieces by the way technically
you don't like thousands of pieces of
the same thing kind of on the homepage
but like for this one well this is a
general we'll start high level with this
one so so basically like this seems like
a click baby title
one thing we we look at like I said
earlier is we're really passionate about
the health of happiness the dogs and we
feel like we need to sometimes we've got
to reach out and grab people to inform
them better so we'll use Debra headlines
for that but then we get into pretty
serious content pretty quickly here's
another one three things from the vet
so we'll put this out and for us the
what we've learned about communities
online or in content generals that
people are more and more looking for
more relevant solutions for themselves
and I think that community is the future
of the Internet is going to be hyper
communities of people there that are
really looking for specific things like
the hustle right so for us it's about
getting those those people and that
final finding them in the internet and
then pinging them and so the idea of
this content there's actually creates a
ton of data for us and here's an example
real quick with just a few versions that
we did that have done over a million
dollars revenue in the past six months
okay it's just to give you guys an idea
of like where versions fall so you're
just testing tons of content right
you're testing tons of content and then
you're gonna find some we're just gonna
win for you but it allows you to do that
in a skin more of a scalable way rather
than write in a hundred pieces of
content from scratch big data is big
business so this is the really neat
thing so when we write content that's
specific so say we write a German
Shepherd we're gonna we're gonna pixel
that user from Facebook we're gonna know
that their German Shepherd owner because
like you don't go read about German
Shepherds let's do that one right so we
write content that brings in people that
we won't identify with then what we do
is we're gonna retarget them and we're
also going to take which we grab emails
that page that'll be about German
Shepherd well actually segment that then
we're gonna retarget them for the
similar stuff so like these all these
variations allow us to create a lot of
data points in regards to content and
then we can use that to make informed
decisions so the way we do that gonna be
targeting so offers specialized emails
and things like that so those variations
is hyper targeted variations allow us to
grab relevant emails for different
things we use the analytics demo data to
better understand how to communicate so
like if certain so we'll look at like
well actually cross-reference a lot of
data and look at the age of owners where
they live knowing that like hey it's
really cold for you you're gonna have
different issues and stuff right now
then we are in you know Southern
California so we use a lot of that data
to make informed decisions about what's
right and we get that from that inbound
here's the interesting part so on
Facebook when we're doing well if any if
we're using Facebook we're actually
targeting based on data they provide and
they're making they're using connecting
points to try to figure out what that
data is and so when you go on their say